that's that's a cat that is tired
they've been using its chalky it's great
this is a talking cat you know what you
would like Kitty crystals instead of
crystal man you would enjoy that for a
short time and then your life would get
out of control but crystals of a pretty
litter cat litter uses crystals and you
know what kitty if you pee on this if
you pee on this cat litter and you're
sick the cat litter will change color to
let your owner know that you're sick
that's so weird but it's science and it
works so why would you why would your
owner trust anything other than pretty
litter at this point user pretty litter
Bobcat well then I hope you're saving
20% now because you can do so at going
to pretty litter calm and using promo
code Nikki yeah oh I have to go pop the
chrysalis change color
[Music]
Craig Ferguson is in studio to up with
Nikki Glaser
Karen pianist here Craig you just heard
played the role of kitty and cat owner
thank you so much for that you know it
it's one of the finest performances not
only did I become the cat but every game
the cats I just didn't see him being
like a redneck that was a surprise
[Laughter]
[Music]
my gosh like to do peepees in Craig
Ferguson is here he has a new book out
called riding the elephant it's a memoir
of sorts a series of essays too hot for
TV these are stories you miss doing the
monologues on your show you must being
able to talk freely and tell stories
I missed the former I don't miss dunno
in the TV but I missed before my telling
stories but these stories are stories
that you know some of them are very sad
yes some of them are dirty and I I kind
of like that some of them are too long
Frank you know but I thought was it was
kind of the idea of doing little stories
about this happened in my life and
here's the story of it I missed having
that ability and so I took the chance of
using a computer in typing how was that
for you that process of writing you know
I like it what happens is I I get my cat
and it sits on the little crystal
changing yeah kitty litter which to me
sounds like a made-up thing it really
does wait my PP is Starla how does that
know it's judging bait my kitty litter
is making fun of judgments about my
behavior my pee changes I'm just like oh
I ate some beans
yes yeah
whenever beats and I get the red yes I
always think I have somewhat cancer
right even although I know I've had
beats I'm like yeah but you know but
what if you had beats on a week that you
get stomach cancer that's just don't eat
beets so you sat down have you written a
book before is this your first doing
your research I'm so impressed that
you've read in three books so is that it
is it a painstaking process compared to
everything else you've done in your
career than everything else because you
just do a little bit every day and then
it adds up yeah and and then it's done
and you don't have to have anyone's
permission and you don't have to talk to
any executives and you don't have to do
live reads can I say the reason I am ah
I have this show is because of Craig
Ferguson I was living in Los Angeles two
years ago and I was a frequent guest on
his show because you were good I was on
it once and just because of he didn't
know I was just through booking the
people and then we hit it off and and
and I had such a good time on the show
and I learned how to be on radio and be
relaxed and they did you created a
setting in which I felt myself and I
could be myself and then you were so
encouraging and so complimentary that
you gave me the confidence to be like I
should be doing this you told me that
yes and that's all I need is just a
compliment from a handsome tall man and
being like you're good at this and I'm
just like I'll do it forever and I'll
pursue it in any way I can totally
thanks for sayin handsome and tall oh my
god that's truly career path I've chosen
I'm like some guy that is handsome told
me that I was good at it and I was like
okay path so I I pursued it and that's I
literally what went right from his
so to hearing about the guess he had a
show on Sirius that I was on all the
time yeah and then they told me that
maybe there was a show opening up at
comedy central radio and I called Comedy
Central and I said can I have it yeah
and then they said that's what we
there's a long list of people we have in
mind and I go well I should be at the
top of that list because I I was I had a
TV show yeah and I'm a really good
shoplifter I was like addicted to it at
a time in my life where I needed to feel
some things yeah feeling steel yeah no I
I'm always kind of impressed with people
who were show up lifters I feel that she
was a certain bravery and enterprise
just don't talk yourself down just push
you were a criminal at some point oh my
god I think you're right I'm shoplifting
again after this no your honor I was
just trying to be encouraging trying to
start a lifter she had just gotten done
saying that she needs a compliment and
then she goes off on a new course in
life and then you told her that it shows
entrepreneurship yeah I I still hold my
breath when I walk through the the
secure metal detect things just because
of so many times in my life I was
nervous they were gonna go off it still
makes me feel adrenaline rush I go into
that for as long as you can I am so old
now when I see cops I think good cops
feel better yeah that's that's I mean
there are things that I look at that I'm
like oh you should be ashamed of those
things but they are kind of brave
like getting work done to your face as a
woman I think is actually the bravest
thing you can do ever you're getting a
needle in your face and we judge these
women like oh she had her face done it's
all up it's like well at least
she took a chance you're not taking she
took a chance in her dream for the rest
I mean it could go really wrong when you
were doing taking that risk I think it's
like one of the bravest saying shoplift
with a faceless I did two tours of Iraq
but I have to say that the bravest thing
I've ever done is get Botox and steal a
pair of Underpants
[Music]
so I was yeah you you have this new book
out riding the elephant what are we
getting out of this book that we didn't
get in your past two books what wives
[Laughter]
before so you might as well just read
this one look if I repeated myself now
it's like Avengers you can just watch it
so the cat litter changes color okay did
you read the book it with that voice you
know I don't know why I started doing
that voice but I have started doing it
well whenever I say anything stupid I
like to use somebody's voice that isn't
mine so I can't blame them oh I think
it's stupid things like that and then I
talk sensibly like beep this week and
I'm like they extinct the most racist
sexist I've ever heard if you want
to be the worst version of yourself to
become a comedy writer and write into
characters but if I said that stuff in
my stand-up act being like
jokingly like I'm saying it for irony no
character but if I I can just be racist
and let all those things out of my head
that are there because you know you are
a racist okay I think the new Negroes is
hiring right
but it is wild that you can just write
these characters say these awful racist
things and then no one in that line
right you know here's one thing I've
learned about the recent climate never
interview an old Irish actor when he's
drunk
[Laughter]
apparently doing interviews while I most
liked it but I will say for your book I
know that who this is going to who would
this would be a good gift for because I
witness a lot I'm on reddit a lot and I
come through reddit and is that like
MySpace no it's like a uh it's a it's a
place where you go and you can sign up
for different feeds that create all of
this content and it lands on one page of
all your interests the most breaking
news of all the interests in your life
and different news stories and funny
things but you're constantly coming up
on reddit old clips from your show or
just celebrations of Craig Ferguson and
it's like Rhett it's really hip and they
like know what's cool and they know what
they they have the right kind of
nostalgia for things it's just a place I
go to for like the forefront of what's
cool reddit loves Craig Ferguson yeah
constantly interviews being posted there
meat on there it is it is it means a lot
to me to love it on reddit yeah so what
I'm saying is every time one of those
clips get posted the comments below or
like he was the best we miss him so much
I use and just celebrating you now there
are so many people out there that feel a
deficit in their lives from not having
you to watch on TV every night is what
we are saying what is actually happening
here although this time it's sort of old
the 1940s not signaling
so it was so okay this is the projection
of you perhaps you should read the book
and the two that preceded it I got a lot
of reading yes we do but if you have
someone in your life who misses Craig
Ferguson this book is what you need to
get for them right now it's riding the
elephant is the name of the book is it
out now I don't know anything next week
7th May 7th Oh oh great Father's Day
gift coming up if you have a dad who
loved Craig Ferguson and watched his
show all the time and just like has
probably been like where is that guy
yeah my solace now is my cat get this
book your dad will be so touched that
you remembered that he was a huge Craig
Ferguson fan and he'll be like oh my god
this is so cool he'll feel seen let your
dad feel be seen this father saying no
choice because you choose to be on radio
where you of course yeah well we have
cameras in studio right now when I got
into radio Craig I really like embrace
the fact that I was never gonna have to
wear makeup or do my hair again and then
now they're in every day and um and I
kind of love it though because listen I
love being on camera it's so much fun
let me tell you about a particular
showing I had on Craig Ferguson's
short-lived serious show but we had so
much fun on there how's your gut what's
this it wasn't shortly lose like two
years right it's too hot for me yeah but
you were having so much fun cuz you
didn't care you were just like oh this
will end someday and I don't care at all
I don't care and I don't care now I
genuinely don't I genuinely don't
ya know it's a very weird place to get
to a little unnerving at times it's kind
of like shoplifting but all the time all
the time it's like what I'm asleep I'm
Chablis what does that feel like - not
did you use to care when did you yeah
yeah when did you lose some of that not
caring what when I interviewed
Archbishop Desmond Tutu and this is a
true story he said you know I was just
like mucking around on TV and he said to
me you know you are crazy and I'm
thinking and I said some father too -
you've talked to some very crazy people
and some of them very evil and he said
yes but you are the type of crazy that
we need so you should be more I don't
know why I'm making him talk like this
is nobody talks like but I don't really
know how to do his voice I can't do his
voice without you know what you mean so
what did he say he said you're the good
kind of crazy said you're the good crazy
you should be as crazy as you want to be
and I feel like coming from Desmond Tutu
that's kind of like God saying you can
be as crazy as you want yeah yeah we're
good good so you you live like that I
try to yeah but you're so nice and
you're just appreciate that you don't
give a crap anymore and you do what you
want because then I know that you're
genuine because I you're nice
and so that's must be who you are I
don't want to be I I don't want to be I
suppose I care a little bit in the sense
that I don't want to be an asshole to
people no I think you can not care and
at the same time no be mean yes I agree
I went on Craig so after I had a lunch
date with this guy who I'd met at a show
a couple nights before oh you heard that
goal did you ever see him do okay so I
went on this lunch date and he was so
cute he was like this comedian British
comedian and I was like I hadn't even
I've gone through every American
comedian I wanted to go through and so I
just every American
you know who it was later because he so
I met about the show in LA Kings we have
this fantastic lunch like if we go
longer than we thought we were going to
we're connecting so much I'm like oh my
god
this is like off to the races he talks
about something that I go just he goes
I'll tell you later like on another the
next time we hang out and I go okay well
why don't you just tell me now and he's
like because I know I'm gonna see you
again and I was like oh my god this is
great that kind of thing right so I I go
hey I have to go because I have to go do
craig ferguson's show I have to go well
it made sense or maybe it would have cuz
I said you can listen don't worry about
the cat litter I noticed a skull of one
of the cats is a little peaky so I went
it's like oh you should listen because I
was feeling like flirty I'm like also
like I'm gonna be about to be him I'm
just like burrowing down with Craig
Ferguson down the block no big deal I'm
pretty spectacular welcome to America
right he goes I have a rental car I have
serious this is great I'll listen I was
like yeah 103 I'll be on in like five
minutes literally it's down the block so
I rush over there I get into studio
Craig goes you look nice because usually
I'm walking in there like whatever but I
was just came from a date name and and
he's like and I go well yeah I just went
on a date and and I talked about it
knowing he was listening but like you
know anyways it would be like flirty and
fun and Craig's asking me about it I'm
like I think it went well I got out of
that and he sent me an emoji immediately
sent me an emoji of the Oh bearing teeth
emoji which some people accidentally
send that thinking it's a big smile I
think people with like autism don't
understand that that's like by this
noise Nicki means no disrespect to
people with or no I don't
just like you don't know how to read
faces as well as other people so you see
teeth and you're like equals smile but
that is no the bear teeth one is like it
goes with that sound of I didn't say
you're like I need these guys a small
then I went back and I know they I think
I went back I went back through my head
and was like what could I said that
upset and I didn't say anything
the problem was I picked the worst
person to do that to do you talk about
him at all because right before me he
had dated a female comic who had just
published a book in which he had been
written about in it so he had just got
and that was the that was the thing he
was gonna tell me on the next date was
who he dated I didn't know I would never
have talked about her eventually much
worse
but he he never followed up with that
second date and I was all about it and I
never heard from him again no we cut it
off at the past like you got to do that
like you probably not an open book that
guy was weird about me saying he was
handsome and I had a good time with him
is he gonna be okay with me being like
he didn't tie me up last night so I
couldn't come like no I see the picture
of this mole a little bit just a slight
question point of order call back early
on the show I was talking about how like
I this weekend I was in Nashville Craig
and that's where I get all my cat for
the cat everybody knows Nashville is for
yeah I flew in some I needed to
have I needed to have an orgasm and I
haven't been able to recently so I flew
in some dick to Nashville we can live in
some OGD a guy that I know knows how to
do it to me so I full because you spend
some money and miles and Adam come in
and
and and and bang me out real good coach
or business coach he brings the
restraints next time he's not flying
that's the thing is like I mean like I
it was fine it was good we had some good
time but I he's gonna need to check a
bag he's gonna get it done he did when
he was coming over he brought the
Hitachi wand which is like my favorite
it's amazing for everything yeah yes
it's this big old one but he had it in
his bag to bring because yeah it's ours
Frank and his bag got he like they
looked at he of water in it so they took
about the bag and the TSA guy goes you
know that women like use these to
pleasure themselves and my axe was just
like oh yeah I've heard that he was like
he claimed to just be bringing a
massager but yeah clearly a sex toy yes
but he's gonna have to bring a bigger
bag the TSA guy have any interest no I
can't believe it's no rights no that
you're gonna rush up and sexually
excited why you've distracted me from my
fly
that's right leg or as a pilot
you've distracted me why that's your tip
you've attacked I say you've attacked my
clitoris with that well that sex toy and
now I'm afraid I can't fly the plane you
could you could do some damage with that
thing to a pilot I think it's a it's a
brutal weapon Oh
two weeks ago sorry to be talking about
masturbation so much Craig I don't know
do you mind no well I the last week Mike
can I bring you into this because you
shared the story with me we were both
talking about how we tried to masturbate
last week and our both of our toys
batteries died died during the process
and you just can't you just don't in
like the backup toys there's not much
they weren't charged yes
and so
for heaven's sake if you can't get
better
apparently Jim Gaffigan is here knock me
with your eighteenth child but it's just
so funny to me that I felt I was
completely in that moment could not do
anything to finish up I was just like
well well that's over I gotta wait three
hours for this thing to charge again but
as a man never been in the middle of
jerking off and just unlike my hand stop
all right and then someone said that you
can get a cramp oh my go that's maybe
something but then you have another hand
that's charge no you have the one hand
you using the other hands it's called
riding the elephant riding the elephant
there's a story about riding an elephant
also it's a metaphor for life why
because it goes where it wants and you
just don't know eventually trample you
yeah maybe yeah yeah yeah and it's
sometimes it's great I think we went too
far when you said the elephant was great
but the masturbation stuff was fine I've
never ridden an elephant before but why
doesn't any animal go where it wants to
I'm not trying to focus
I don't know I think I think that's a
fair a fair point and if you read the
book you'll see that I address it okay I
actually be something that I brought up
a lot in my first two books mr.
Shakespeare is your first place Craig
I'm so glad you're back on radio yeah
only for a short time yeah that so you
you don't miss the show it just became a
grind yeah you were doing it in your on
your property yeah yeah do it a little
what's that what's going on in that
house now
well it's available yeah I'm selling it
oh you really are you're selling your
house hi Scotland really happen in
Scotland most of the time for the past
year and your whole family your son and
everybody everyone yeah they all have
red hair now so you're done with LA with
LA yes yeah yeah I think I spend more
time in New York I think I like New York
I'm done with LA right I was there for
20 yeah it's too dusty it is dusted
yesterday and there's you're getting out
right before like an earthquake's gonna
happen you don't even need to go back
now Scotland you don't need to go back
I'm worried about that earthquake I'm
thinking about moving back to LA and I'm
like I just don't want to deal with an
earthquake it's not like I'm scared of
dying in one I'm just like I know my
worst fear is I'm gonna be like finally
have time to take a good three-hour nap
and then an earthquake starts and I'm
like I got to deal with an earthquake
what do you do well your house starts
falling off its foundation it's flying
all over and they're gonna do just relax
no you're gonna go outside golden pipes
are breaking there's hissing noises
going off you might die yeah by being
around cats
why that's the worst of all color
earthquakes are so annoying like it's
gonna disrupt your life a lot you're
gonna have to be out on your lawn
talking to your neighbors about like can
we go back in yet or when it's and if
it's really kind of struct it cratis
traffic then you got up that's what I'm
looking for is like a guy who is
prepared for the apocalypse like I'm
really turned on by that no that's like
the worst thing I'm so scared of all of
it yeah it's like sometimes I mean it's
just like when I have an opportunity to
take a nap I just want to not be
disrupted by anything there are times
when I'm on a plane and the turbulence
is so bad and I'm like if there's a
crash right now I can't deal with this
I'm just I'm too tired to like download
the Wi-Fi so I can say goodbye to my
loved ones right I remember the passcode
that I might have already signed up for
a Boingo account in the past and I
remember vibe I have to have going go
send me a password so I can say goodbye
to my mom she knows I loved her so like
I don't know like it's it's funny to me
though that there are times where I
think the planes crashing and I'm like I
just I'm too tired to tire are you tired
anymore I think that I'm always a little
tired to go through a crash yeah it's
like but are you exhausted still like I
know there have been times in your life
where you definitely said yes to
everything and you did everything you
were doing it you were doing a live show
every day and you like do you are you
you're still sleep deprived no no no I
you look great that's the thing you look
like so I'm alright yeah I was on TV
this morning so I'm wearing makeup
on the rest of the day oh yeah I don't
have time to take it off my busy show
business oh my god guys look so much
better with makeup and they don't even
know I don't even know that he's wearing
makeup right now guys could get away
that's true you shouldn't be doing this
every morning you know I could it would
behoove you to wear some concealer I
want to put mascara on my boyfriend Oh
guys my mascara look so hot he won't let
me though crack you would look so hot
with mascara I would so someone wrote me
yesterday uh I was hanging with a guy
there was a joke on veep about concealer
right no and he stopped in goes what's
can see I had explained to him I had to
joke in my act I don't do it anymore cuz
I dated an actor he was like BIP this is
concealer on it what are you trying to
conceal like the dark circles under my
eyes
shadows one of the first things I
noticed when I started doing late night
is you meet actors who are super famous
and and you and they're like you think
they're really clever and then you
realize no you just you have clever
people write things down and you
remember the words yeah they're
memorization Elise yeah that's and then
you think they can be charming though
but they're not that well as long as you
keep it about that yes but the minute
you wander off into another like talking
about cats
[Music]
yeah I mean I would god I wish I could
talk to you more about that because it
is as I do this show and I talk to more
people come through doing press stuff
and these people that you project all
the stuff onto because you've seen them
play roles that are so fascinating thing
that is true is that Henry Winkler is
the nicest man the nicest angry wing you
50 years since he did the phones people
go up to him and say hey fozzy hey and
he goes hey phones and he gives them a
throne people come is five years since
I've done late-night he's gonna say hey
Greg where's Jeff I'm like your
mom I was such a big pimple under my
beard that's the beauty of a beard I
know cover-up I haven't thing can you
even fit you can stay here and it's huge
you go yeah yeah I see it hold on don't
have it this is your trash one man's
trash it will hold on yeah I see it
yeah that hurts yeah it's telling good
good yeah
but man if I did have a beard yeah then
I would just be hanging out for your
face and you wouldn't be able to get
work no way
[Music]
what's happening with these sunglasses
why why I bought them yesterday my 38
bucks and you forgot to bring the case
and now you just have to wear them on
your head
yeah also a lot of celebrities were they
do yeah like who who are you thinking
you look like right now because I know
it's someone like Pete Davidson would
wear Machine Gun Kelly whoo Emily these
are men half your age you're comparing
yourself to okay older guys anyone from
the stones Aerosmith Mick Jagger would
wear glasses like when do you get to the
point where you get to wear glasses I'm
soft wear glasses inside my eyes are
like the number one thing that I'm
always like oh god if I could take
something out of this photo would be
that really oh yeah all the time
your blue eyes yeah I would take out
yeah cuz I always look tired so my ideal
thing I guess would be this to cover up
the bags oh so it's just to blow your
eyes yeah yeah it's always below max are
you an actual and it's this don't who's
it insecure about their eyeballs some
people with brown eyes cuz brown eyes is
the worst thing Gusti what do you have
I'm hazel green I was black hazel green
equals brown okay that is one nice way
to say Brown is hazel coming from
freaking Nazi eyes over here Wow we
can't all have all Nazi blue I have
hazel green you can look that's right
too close
she could just zoom in on oh you don't
have to go to a Nazi blue eyes um all
right maybe it's distracting it's it's
totally is yeah that's why people do it
because then they could be disconnected
and they're cool and no one questions
you do look cooler with them and I don't
like it yeah what are these jeans are
these new jeans they're blue jeans
oh they're Levi's I've heard wearing
lighter jeans I was gonna get really
light jeans but none of them fit me
because I have what they call a shitty
body why don't the jeans fit you cuz I
wear like 33 30s mm-hmm
and you do not wear a thorough for in Z
for watching I thought you meant waist
33 30 no okay
well my waist is 33 Oh your waist is 33
okay that makes more so a lot of guys
designers a lot of designer jeans will
be 32 32 34 32 there's very few 33 30
because it's a why it's like a pair
right they don't want us they don't want
people with my body wearing their jeans
I think yeah it's a way it's like when
Abercrombie or asked the Jersey Shore
not to wear their clothes
Abercrombie thought they were better
than the jury Robby paid the Jersey
Shore to not wear their clothes that
backfired because that shorts still
going strong you got one in jail right
he's killing it and then Pauly D has a
show it's funny though because yeah that
they well I think is Abercrombie doing
well I don't like this maybe perfume
right yeah I mean they're still around
that's gotta say something
yeah that's what my I think there should
be a plan in place to take every fur
coat that's ever been made and donated
it to homeless people that way the
homeless are wearing fur it the fur is
not being wasted but then no one wants
to look homeless so now the homeless
look will be an unattractive look
therefore no one else will buy fur great
idea yes good idea I'm a bit defer on
the homeless will look shitty because
they'll be out it but then still a solid
new fur might look even better compared
to a homeless for me homeless people
wear fur coats if we get if we cold
together every fur coat that is not
being worn and give them all of the
homeless people and then New York City
is all the homeless are decked out and
fur
you will then associate fur with being
homeless therefore no one wants to look
homeless I'm not being anti homeless no
one likes to look homeless I'm sorry if
that's offends you watching this the
homeless person who's watching this but
no one wants to look like you you're
homeless it's not a good look it seems
like a hard life you don't want to look
like you're having a hard life therefore
people won't buy fur anymore and we will
just much like Abercrombie thought that
if the Jersey
Abercrombie no one would wear it this is
my I think we should get the Jersey
Shore to wear fur that's what I'm just
getting to know are they homeless um
nikki has a podcast no he's doing great
but uh you know Kay Wow
yeah Angelica I don't know about her she
came in late she did come in late I
remember that she had her suitcases were
trash bags and I respected that homeless
you just saw a clip from you up with
Nikki Glaser check here every Tuesday
for a new clip from my radio show you up
with Nikki Glaser from our radio show
with you up with Andrew and Nicky never
Andrew Collins radio show who happens
that Nikki on some done okay we all know
that's not true